hola todos bienvenidos trailer
commentaries I am Spencer Shay Gilbert
that's Joestar that's Dan merle and if
you're wondering why i spoke spanish cuz
i'm learning but I also have another
language aficionado here an ASL
interpreter Brian car ooh thank you for
joining us absolutely thanks for having
me and thank you so much for helping out
with the quiet place honest trailer we
wanted to do something a little
different for this one because it's a
good movie and good movies are boring to
talk about so we thought we'd latch on
to the the sign language and that it is
ASL in this movie right right American
Sign Language yeah and and we bring in a
translator so congratulations that you
might be one of the first people who's
appeared on camera and an honest trailer
there aren't yeah you're just need to
figure it out it was the red lava geyser
intermedia way back when yeah and Jon
Chu times and I couldn't think of I'm
sure Jordan Voigt Roberts Jordan Roberts
that's right for this fella yeah yeah if
it's your first time watching we are
gonna talk about the honest trailer for
a quiet place and if you stick around to
the end you'll see some cut jokes and
some things that didn't make it into the
final final cut that you saw there but
first we're just gonna give general
thoughts impressions of the movie I
liked it it's damn good
I was surprised and thrilled and
titillated not too late just enjoy I
really enjoyed it
what about you Joe yeah that's why I'm
so glad it worked out having Brian come
in to do this because it was gonna be
four minutes of us going this was an
excellent film if we didn't have a fun
angle to play with so yeah worked out
yeah I really like this there's a lot
there's some where we know we're gonna
John robust a little bit and this with
that with our trailer and the sense of
like we have to do something different
here cuz that's the angle otherwise I
know that we briefly discussed it being
completely silent with only subtitles
but then we were like they whisper plus
it's like I think that what tried it
might be funny for like 30 seconds I
think we decided and then it's like four
minutes and be a little much yeah so it
got to John
this is good deep epic was an epic wish
it's a very epic whisper yeah I thought
that was a comedic line I liked that
when he said alright that's better and
then whisper yeah yeah I I did enjoy the
the the fact that you guys brought an
interpreter I just thought that it was a
great kind of nod to the deaf community
to have their language represented so I
appreciate that
well did you feel the same way about the
movie right like one of the actresses is
actually deaf right Millicent Simmons
that that's why I know that the deaf
community actually from what I've heard
has received it very well and so you
know anytime you put sign language in a
movie it's under the scrutiny yeah the
deaf community and so from what I've
heard this has been taking very well
cool who uh what are some bad examples
of sign language in in film well I don't
want to throw anybody under the bus oh
that's what we do because I do enjoy a
lot of films that I see American sign
language in although well we will always
nitpick it a little bit I think John
wake to yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean I
could nitpick it she did really well
considering I know that she's not a
native speaker she hasn't been signing a
long time but you know yeah it's it's
under the microscope anytime you see
something on the shore did like just
Kaczynski and Emily Blunt did they do
well in this movie they did so you could
tell that they weren't native users but
I think that like actually plays well to
the story because usually parents to
deaf children they don't learn sign
language and tell their children start
learning sign right yeah and so it kind
of shows that they've been signing for
you know a few years a handful of years
so it was actually pretty accurate yeah
so that worked out perfectly yeah that's
a good point I was gonna say cuz they
probably started post-apocalypse but no
they probably started when they're when
their daughter was born because she
predates write the apocalypse cuz it was
been yeah a year and I think or just a
little bit more than a year yeah
don't think there's many sign language
classes post apocalypse the Community
College survived and then there's yeah
there are some venues where you could go
if it did that teacher cleans up
to teach everything that's the sequel so
why don't we take a look at the honest
trailer for hit it JT oh thanks
in a world full of loud movies starring
loud people play to theater scroll of
loud fans one premise will shock and
horrify the modern audience though
that's better a quiet place pause Dan
didn't you say that your theater-going
experience for this movie was somewhat
ruined by people talking no you just
always said no that's often the case but
no I heard anecdotes of hereditary being
ruined by many people by bad audiences
but I would imagine there were probably
a few screenings that were also ruined
by audiences for this one I'm very lucky
I get to go to mostly critic screenings
so they're they're very well behaved but
I can imagine a bad audience would
definitely hinder your enjoyment in this
film I imagine a lot of just even
crinkling uh you know yeah we're not
sure this is something you want to watch
maybe even alone with headphones yeah I
well I had to watch this in a room with
you guys with headphones and I was
trying I was really into this movie and
I was trying really hard to make sure
you guys didn't notice me and my corner
of the office going like yeah yeah cuz I
look like an idiot yeah that's good so
quiet down kids let's keep going I have
told it could no we're not that's a
quiet place hey can we get an epic ASL
guy to help me out here hey Brad Hey
explore the near future of a quiet place
on one hand it's a dystopia where blind
aliens kill anyone who makes us out
but on the other it's every dad's
paradise so well yeah we'll get into
that in a second but Brian is it hard to
keep up with John is what's the pace
like is this is this tough to do or
could you do this in your sleep that is
incredibly difficult yeah
the pace is super fast there's a lot of
loaded loaded terminology that sometimes
requires expansions and so I was trying
to figure out the most economic way I
could sign it to keep up and I was gonna
ask if they sped up the frame rate a
little bit they did yeah but this is
just a smidge a little bit now I was so
we went into this and in my head I was
like well we always see you know once or
twice a year a viral video goes out of
like a wu-tang concert or something like
that and like someone they have like an
ASL interpreter signing like rappers and
they're just flying so in my head I cut
week I kind of went into this like oh
someone will do it it's fine it's easy
and then you came in and I was because I
was the one working with you on this and
you're like well talk about what
expansions being a little bit it's like
there's a move because you literally
have to sign like there's a movie it's
called a quiet place yeah the so
expansions are just something that
sometimes an ASL it takes more signs to
explain what something means than a few
English words right but it goes back and
forth you can do the same thing
usually not when you're talking about
hearing culture references but so if you
say oh welcome to a quiet place I have
to say Oh welcome you know the movie
called quote quiet place and I've got to
spell it all out and I've got to be
accurate and I have to make sure that
all my my fingerspelling is clear and
it's hard to keep up you know every
letter that I'm signing you just rolls
off your tongue in a matter of seconds
so it also gives me carpal tunnel but
you can't do quiet place you got to
spell it right is so those are that's
part of the ASL rules the grammar which
is completely different it's got its own
grammar its own language structure and
rules and so one of the rules is is any
pronoun you're supposed to spell okay so
your name
title of a movie a location the only I
guess exception would be if you have
name signs like for instance my name
sign is just B DC and that's what deaf
people know me as so there's a few
things that you can do some tools to
kind of consolidate but in this case I
did have to spell out the whole thing I
didn't have a chance to really spell it
everything I wanted to because of the
speed but yeah it's quite a limiting
factor when you're working on a timeline
yeah so that was a little bit like when
we a few years ago for transformers 4 we
had someone come in and translate our
script into Chinese yeah and she was
working on it and she would hit a thing
and she'd be like there's no word for
that I have to I have to give you the
equivalent because that's not a real
word
so we found out is that we we tend to
write in a style that is not easily
translatable to American doubling those
that worked got it yeah okay let's keep
watching finally get some peace and
quiet with plenty of time for fishin
farm-to-table yeah as I watched the
first half of this movie being like
that's the life dude we like Dre lives
another layer watch the offices is John
Krasinski he grew he's more than just a
pretty gym face but a wide buzz yeah how
do you translate Jim John face I don't
know so I know he looks adorable and
he's a very specific adorable though he
looks to camera and I tried to replicate
that I did and so I kind of use this is
kind of a sign it kind of means I don't
know naive prudish kind of I don't know
he's he's not rock and roll in your face
gritty right so and then I have to try
and mimic the face so I just kind of
goofy but the first time I signed it on
that take
I accidentally signed the sign for I
love you so I hope nobody knew
everybody's gonna notice they're gonna
tear me to shreds but I actually signed
I love you which is really close but the
second time I think I want them to cut
you some slack I hope they do because
challenges you discussed aside like you
hit these all I think we did the most we
did on one was like three takes mm-hmm
well that and I had about a day or so to
prepare mhm so like you were mentioning
the wu-tang interpreters I don't even
know what the hell they're saying it's
super fascinates cranked up their frame
rate to like a thousand so but they you
know if you know the lyrics you know
what they're saying you can follow
you've got the right context for that
for the song but but yeah a day to
practice with that speed it was pretty
difficult so you know cut me some slack
slack cut let's keep going
Jim pieces with support from real-life
wife Emily blonde the most badass female
character that's also barefoot pregnant
and not allowed to speak but it's behind
the camera where JK really shines as he
makes a directing debut that's one part
Ridley Scott one part james cameron
titanic references this is weird and
1604 shot this might have been
subconsciously
Tarantino
[Music]
anyone go back you know what enchantee
no one really sees let's go oh no it
came out this year I wonder if the city
knows listen like the baby roll the beat
that's every time I'm glad that worked
out some additional horror movie premise
no other songs you don't think too hard
about it where everyone always looks
like they're holding a board because
knees would equal death now pause as I'm
sure someone will point out in the
comments is a they asked this to John in
an interview John hey and he said it's
I'm actually not recalling it exactly
but it was something to the tune of but
mufflers of like farting into a pillow
thing like silenced underwear pants and
that you can fart into same with
sneezing and burping like have the
explanation yeah I have an answer though
he didn't think about that or the the
little boy on set or the son asked him
about what to do that's a little
inconsistent though cuz like the
beginning they're in the store and
little kids like running around on the
tile floors but then the spaceship is
gonna drop and like they like run and
jump and slide under the grab and like
wasn't that louder than it would have
been to let the thing it's very very
specific about what is loud enough and
what is not loud enough yeah to attract
them I think it's whatever the plot
requires to be loud enough is loud
enough and yeah that's a good point that
you pointed out because in the beginning
he's running around barefoot just
slapping his feet and then later he's
covering his tracks with lights and so
right is it linoleum or tile I guess is
a yeah that's a no-go look yes you can
nitpick this also it's like well the
aliens could have been distracted then
there's only three of them you know they
can't be everywhere at once but yeah
this was he was so good at directing I
don't want to like let that slide past
is this was such an amazing debut that
none of that stuff annoyed me like no
usually if it's a bad movie you do start
getting in your head about the rules of
this well that's that would never
but this is totally invested the whole
time any movie if you stop and think
about it is ridiculous
almost movie if you actually sit down
and logically pieces it's whether or not
those thoughts into your mind when
you're watching it or not yeah and this
yeah I agree this one did not I didn't
sit there thinking like well that's
inconsistent right but it does raise
some questions if you wanted to maybe do
the sequel about I don't know quieter
places quieter places farting and
quieter places I didn't have a question
because when we did the references run
in here with like Titanic and Ridley
Scott so how do you set those up is that
similar to Jim faces like there's a guy
named Jim he was a character from the
office yeah given the time restraints I
just had to make a decision and I just
tried to go with their last names hmm I
had to kind of just consolidate and so I
was hoping that on screen the references
that you were using the clips will
hopefully sufficient - yeah kind of fill
in the blanks of what perhaps a deaf
person watching would miss and so Scott
you know and of course I said director
and kind of prefaced it with movie
director and so Scott Cameron Tarantino
however I think Cameron I ended his last
name with an R which is not correct but
hopefully they got the reference camera
again time and take so hey know better
than we could have done yes
you spend us shrugging multi languages
to my barely one so alright let's keep
watching Deb's are too loud but snapping
your fingers is fine and where this
waterfall that you be isn't that's one
interesting well they don't just live
next to the waterfall I mean come on
don't get me started on the ending the
government's already developing it under
the Denver Airport
pause Joe this was your addition is this
is on me doing some research oh yeah man
we're pretty Utah
yeah you got to read up on the Denver
Airport man that's [ __ ] is yes like
you said this to me like it was a thing
I should have known you were like yeah
that Denver Airport guys Menotti is
underneath yeah well we've had funny
convert uh conspiracy theory
conversations before so I figured Denver
Airport would be one that you were like
oh yeah that one's hilarious
yeah there's the den for reports like
legitimately weird I don't think it's
actually where the Illuminati lives but
it's shaped like the swastika and
there's all just there's like giant
underground bunkers under it and there's
just weird
Nazi paintings everywhere hmm it's a
weird voice it is yes it's incredible
like you're walking it's like no airport
needs to be this big it's insane
weird I've never been I will admit that
I really forced that in mainly because I
wanted our whoever our ASL interpreter
ended up being turned out to be Brian I
really wanted someone to have to sign
the government is developing sonic rolls
off the tongue yeah I don't know how
well that was conveyed something's being
made under that Airport turn on closed
captioning you know hopefully they won't
have to for that part yeah that's a
weird sentence Joe the government's
making something under that damn Airport
look I get to cross something off my
short list so what else is on their
career happy yeah oh remake three ninjas
oh okay with just me playing girls this
is my shortlist smell like one ninja
have dinner at Jack's peas which is my
favorite regional fast food place that's
not like a hard thing to accomplish it's
pretty I just miss it oh really good
chicken port so if you love survival
horror movies and feature-length ASMR
videos strap in
but carefully because the straps can get
like really noisy for a film that
started its life as a potential
Cloverfield sequel so Google hands a big
tuna became a really solid one awful big
tuna come on ma
I hope the Deaf audience knows who big
tuna is cuz I didn't know who big tuna
was it's a pretty obscure obvious
reference so that one's is a deep cut
for the for the people who wash in a lot
of office okay well they got the
smelling okay guys a pronoun that's a
praying
yeah okay great big tuna preserved in
both languages get gone don't need a
sequel unless it's like a super quiet
aliens came over game over stars I would
watch a sequel it just or more of a
reimagining where everyone has to be
making noise all the time or else so
everyone is just me when I'm by myself
yeah and then they finally like get
tired
it's like those dancing contests were
the last person stay aliens exactly yeah
there's some different places you can
take it but uh the premise I don't think
you necessarily need to go the
Cloverfield direction no I don't think
so I think we know there were other
people yeah but then the question
becomes like at what point is it just
diminishing returns and you know you do
it again but if you're just doing it the
same thing it's like well yeah what are
you gonna bring to it what's new what's
the twist unless you're like just
starting at the end and going forward
from there like this family and you like
I don't know I don't think it's fertile
enough grant I think it's just like a
really really good one off it is like
this could honestly be a Twilight Zone
episode but they made a movie out of it
because when you add the
characterization and you care about the
family and stuff like that that's got
yourself a picture yeah that's a picture
yeah green light green light that's
let's see starring dunder muffin okay
that cazzo thank you for not making me
interpret that I think I included the
Clipper we bailed out on it sometimes we
pitch touring ideas that we just to the
room just to like try to make each other
shake our heads okay I was like what's
the dumbest office pun I could possibly
think of you found it Thunder muffle
under was
I was actually the the original script
that I got had mute Guyver good guy yeah
and so I ran that by my friend who's
deaf and an ASL professor and one of my
mentors and he goes no you can't do you
can't there's no equivalent yes we've
got away with words Shikari oh spaceship
spaceship spaceship literally turning it
to 11 starring the same aliens as after
earth well they sent sound instead of
fear anyone else they ever made Jon redo
this to make it even longer I thought it
would have been fun to interpret is it
the same that's what would have made it
fine perfect that's a good reminder that
monopoly sucks and we'll get you killing
the apocalypse as if he ever needed
another reason not to believe in ah
believe it's you that hates monopoly
right Spencer who likes Manama I'm just
gonna pretend that means you're welcome
so what did you say that I do so I like
that because I was able to use a similar
handshape for thank you I'm good and a
muted version of [ __ ] off it kind of
means kind of screw you or go after self
but not as explicit as the middle finger
all right yeah so there's many ways you
can do that but yeah it's kind of like
an homage to like old Italians yeah
but yeah so I just said so thank you
interpreter and I said that's a good
thing right yeah I handed that to post
him just like okay Kevin so like you
know it does thing and then he'll just
we need to time it up so that he signs a
[ __ ] you or whatever and I was like
you'll know what it is the most clear
right there shoutout by the way Kevin
and TJ on this one because any time we
kind of messed with the formula that
it's twice as hard for them because
we're out of our rhythms we're doing
different stuff with the pacing sound
effects and they they really it's an
opportunity to grow yeah Lex the
creative muscles exactly the more work
the last minute when I used to edit them
I loved that but it is it is also more
pressure because you know the
conventional the more conventional ones
you do kind of have a workflow and a
rhythm and a pace and you know how long
it's gonna take you to do something and
yeah and when you've messed it up a
little bit it's like oh okay
and honestly props because if if if I
was an editor and you sat me down and
you were like match this language that
you don't know at all to I would have
shut down I honestly just would have
completely shut down and been like I was
really impressed actually the the cut
that Mac sent me the first time I
watched it I thought I don't know how
they did it but they managed to line it
up very well so I don't know if they
watched a YouTube video in ASL or what
but it did it lined up very well so hats
off good Thompson Kevin and TJ yeah
right we've got great editors let's see
what they cut what else we got worst
sambar actual Mary Poppins y'all your
thumbs and Gondor calls for aid it's
tough to see that see this
Wow jump scares
pause silent this movie just to go for a
little digression I almost wish it
didn't have a score yeah I think that
sometimes I was wondering what was music
and what was actually happening and I
wish that it was just like they really
committed and made it largely signed I
don't think it did at one point sure for
a lot long stretches it doesn't but
there's definitely swells of orchestra I
mean if in the process of making it I
think the decision later in the game
yeah I think I remember reading the the
score was a decision later in the game
and subtitles yeah we're decision later
in the game because at first they were
just going to have the audience like not
really what they're signing and just
sort of kind of figured out live with it
and then they decided to give it to the
scene where he's like you can't ever go
in there and he's trying to give her her
implant yeah mm-hmm cuz it's like a
really strong scene and they're like we
really want people to know that one but
then it was like well if you have one
scene with subtitles and you kind of get
it the whole thing is there's a DVD or a
blu-ray thing where you can isolate to
get rid of music or something like that
and because you can turn off subtitle
tracks the interests now oh yeah
that would actually be really cool did I
tell you guys when we were doing the
honest trailer for dawn of the Planet of
the Apes and the YouTube or iTunes or
whatever however we converted the movie
had stripped the subtitles out and I
didn't realize it till like an hour
because like they really immerse you
into the whole culture here with they're
just talking to each other and I
realized that they'd been subtitles the
whole movie I just I remember that how
do you know what the monkeys are saying
subtitles flat anyways what are the
other titles we don't speak this house
institutions that's good stores
Cooper's I guess that's one way to make
a baby sleep yeah that's definitely not
in a baby books so how would you have
sign that oh that's a great question
yeah I kind of I ran it by my friend and
I thought about it I was hoping that if
you kept it it was just gonna show the
clip and I can point to it because I
don't want to have to sign there's a
baby that I'm you know I know I'm an
interpreter but I do have a sense of
humor and I thought it would've been a
fun comical opportunity to kind of just
look at it well thank you for being game
Brian we really think that you put
yourself out there to be save some
fairly stupid things that we wrote hey
thanks for having me I'm glad I could
actually throw some sign language in the
video you know gives it something a
little different yeah alright I'll
change your pace
yeah no this was nice cuz you never know
how something's going to turn out and
we've got to walk out of that session
like okay that's good let's go work just
gonna work real good yeah I was a bit
nervous at first but yes at the end it
worked out great I'm super super excited
about thank you guys well thank you man
yeah and thank you Joe Starr and thank
you Dan Morelle thank you and thank
myself really for being here come back
next week where we will be one up our
song we're gonna one-up ourselves great
pun you'll figure it out from there
thanks for watching bye bye
you
[Music]